ADA ADA Byron as she initially was ADA
Lovelace's she became what was so
special about her in terms of her
education genealogy if you like her
genetics what was so special about her
that enabled her to do what she did well
this is not strictly computer science
but it's a good story
it does have some marginal relevance to
all of this
ADA's parents were George Gordon Byron
he was born in 1788 I'll put the first
name of his wife in quotes actually she
was christened I think as an Isabella
but she actually liked to run the two
together and he lied them into Annabella
so that's why I put the quotes around
Annabella boom Milbank they got married
in 1815 and you can work it out I mean
that would mean that byron was 27
she was actually 23 and very shortly
after getting married they had a
daughter and Byron chose the name ADA
for her you know sort to the point
poetical ADA Byron born 10th of December
1815 she was the only legitimate
daughter of these two now I can only
apologize again and say I have to say
something about particularly her father
because it explains so much about Ada
and how she was educated the way she was
Lord Byron was unbelievable he was the
Victorian bad boy par excellence George
Gordon Byron was like an amalgam of
Hunter as Thompson you know Sean Penn
Charlie Sheen Keith Richards maybe all
of the bad boys and it had there been a
gang of them a Rat Pack he would have
been the leader most definitely indeed
hey one of his many many girlfriends for
George Byron was a lady called Lady
Caroline Lam
some of the oldest of my audience will
have seen the movie starring Sarah miles
and famously Lady Caroline
characterized him as being mad bad and
dangerous to know he writes like a
housemaid on the verge of the vapors
mean to like Lord Byron was famous at
Cambridge for keeping a pet bear in his
rooms and when he later declared himself
to be a poet and he was a very good one
he went off to Italy to see his
political friends and had them visit him
people like Shelley and Keats and stuff
like that
Shelley recounts that when he found
Byron by the sea in lodgings the
staircase was occupied by six pet
peacocks it was this kind of excess it
was sex drugs and rock and roll except
no rock and roll in those days so his
sex drugs and poetry
if he doesn't rolls-royce it would have
been in a swimming poison oh yes yes yes
yes because he was like that and because
he left his wife immediately five weeks
after ADA was born and they'd only been
married earlier that year that Annabella
Milbank thought he was the devil
incarnate had no time for him and was
worried stiff that daughter ADA might
grow up in the image of her father so to
try and head off trouble at the pass it
was decreed that ADA's education could
cover things like nonfiction English
literature geography botany mathematics
physics chemistry nothing that involved
the emotions the thing that was
absolutely bound in her education was
poetry that's inflamed at the passions
she might start taking after her father
and then heaven knows what what happened
so ADA unusually for a woman of breeding
in early Victorian era had a very
rational scientific upbringing she had
mathematics tutors and later on actually
in wanting to become an even better
mathematician she did ask what she not
only took up with Babbage as we'll find
out but she also asked for
recommendations for other tutors and one
of them is a person I think I have men
non-computer father already or guess
just de Morgan who came up with the
rules of the logical algebra later known
as boolean algebra so she had de Morgan
of de Morgan's rules fames has one of
our Massachusetts she was serious about
becoming ever more devoted to
mathematics think about it 1815 she was
a society lady she lived with her mother
and a large proportion of living with a
mum during the year would be in London
in rented lodgings yes her mother was
reasonably well-off she was a minor
league sort of IRS in her own right they
could afford that okay but young ladies
are breeding really up until about 1970
in the society circuit had had a
ceremony almost of what was called
coming out what it meant is you were in
debutantes you were a young lady in
society who hadn't been formally
introduced so the people who mattered in
societies so you had coming-out balls in
fashionable London and these were
attended by the Queen because of course
by the time you by the queen or the king
when you had 17 on to 1815 1832 was
ADA's coming-out ball where she met the
predecessor to Queen Victoria whose King
William before I think about time but
anyway as part of this coming out she
met at one of the events a certain
Charles Babbage and Charles Babbage
invited Ada and her mother Annabella to
come and visit him at his house meet his
wife and to be shown this miracle of
mechanical engineering and mathematics
so only Park constructed but we're just
waiting more funds difference engine
mark to and ADA was completely
captivated by this she thought it was
wonderful and she and Babbage became
shall we say firm friends corresponding
very very regularly they kept in touch
but in order to explain how it all came
down in the end to this analytical
engine he goes roughly as follows in the
early 1830s
Haeju still only 19 corresponding a lot
with Babbage about his Difference Engine
mark to ask for recommendations for
maths tutors and so
late 1830s was occupied by the factors
in about 1835 I think ADA met another
gentleman from high society called
William King Merrigan they fell for each
other whirlwind romance mid-1830s so the
late 1830s you can imagine was spent on
William Kings
Somerset estates in the process of being
domestic and having three children and
fortunately for ADA
very unusual in the Victorian era they
did all survive
and she herself did not die in
childbirth minor miracle in those days
but by early 1840s she'd had her three
children of course they were well enough
off they'd be looked after by
governesses nursemaid and so on she
decided that she would like to get back
into mathematics and it was at this late
stage that Babbage without actually
formally publishing his anywhere had
come up with the idea of the analytical
engine keep it in the CPU or if you
Babbage of course would have been the
first programmer in a sense of his
analytical engine he'd have come up with
the design and even had some paper
exercises about with that design will
this actually work but don't forget the
analytical engine was not built has not
been built and will cause huge problems
in being built
however the spec could be obtained and
it was very very impressive indeed so
why didn't Babbage publicize this more
why did Ada and others have to find out
almost by knowing him personally
the answer is Babbage was thin-skinned
think back to my story in earlier videos
about Newton and Gauss they were
thin-skinned couldn't stand criticism
couldn't stand the unwashed criticizing
their great thoughts but like Newton he
hated publishing if you published then
the great unwashed would start telling
the B oceans I think it was called by
Gauss same thing with back
he was so thin-skinned he could not take
criticism and worst of all he stopped
giving lectures because people
misunderstood him and worse still he got
heckled so it was no use asking Babbage
to give a lecture to the Royal
Institution or something in London about
his analytical engine not gonna do that
however he was invited to go to Italy
and I think he was probably a member of
the Italian equivalent of the Royal
Society so he went over by invitation in
the late 1830s to give a talk on his
analytical engine a person there called
- eg menabrea an engineer with a good
maths background who later became
Italian Prime Minister actually took
copious notes and wrote up a paper
published in a French journalist an
Italian one amazingly well
ada got to hear about this and got hold
of a copy of it and decided that she
could rework it as translator add a lot
to it doing letter and explained it to
an English audience so this is where the
whole issue comes of Ada as computer
programmer yes she really really did
understand every nuance of Babbage's
design she had to in explaining how this
program worked in no doubt writing
programs of her own and I think what all
'some presses me about ada when you read
her copious notes at the end of this
paper beware it's in Victorian English
it is heavy going
she and Babbage and the rest the
Victorians would never use six words
where 36 would do all sorts of
subjunctive clauses always hard work be
warned
so anyway in part of our endnotes in
this she lets her imagination run free
and she says to people you know have you
thought could this wonderful engine of
Babbage's compose music really is good
lateral thinking because Sean and I have
stood there at Bletchley Park or sat
there in front of my computer here at
Nottingham when we
the Ackermann function and jokingly said
to ourselves who is thinking when the
result in command and somehow that's not
too difficult to thought to have when
the thing is aleck tronic and humming
away but to have the thought of this
crashing great analytical engine being
driven by steam going bang crash bang
bang - think of that as a thinking
machine I think does require a big leap
of imagination so yes she had glimpses
of the future there's no question about
it she really did even more so if you
think that it's actually just on paper
at this stage oh yes she's seen some
cogs from other things he's done yes
later on after her sort of tragic death
Babbage when he wrote his own
autobiography referred back constantly
to what he called his enchantress of
number ie
Ada herself and this this wonderful
paper Oh another lovely babby story I
love this one she consulted him while
she was writing this paper and he
thought it was wonderful but came up
with a great idea which you can guess
wouldn't it be a good idea my dear if as
well as this paper I were to write an
anonymous preface to it and flame the
establishment and the ground givers for
not giving me enough to actually build
it and she knew him well enough by this
time she adroitly avoided doing that
I mean Babbage his idea that so long as
it was anonymous nobody would guess who
wrote it and just unbelievable anyway
that's how it all ended because the
trouble was and the really tragic thing
for ADA was as the eighteen forties wore
on her health got worse and worse and
worse it's now believed that she
actually died of cervical cancer I think
she didn't actually die till 1852 by
that time her mother had moved in with
her and her husband William king of
levelers on their summer sets of state
but a week or two before ADA died of
rupture ins began all over again because
she she called William King her husband
apparently according to her Stephen
Wolfram log and I believe this is
researched
well and told William King something
that made him very very upset this has
not been recorded what it is she
insisted that when she died and she knew
death was inevitable as she did not want
to be buried on the William King Earl of
Lovelace estate in Somerset she wanted
to be buried next to her father and this
if you like is where the local bait
comes in for us here in Nottingham her
father George Gordon Lord Byron when he
wasn't being mad bad and dangerous to
know had also actually inherited from a
very distant byron cousin the whole of
the new state obviously now Houston
Abbey is a stately home just north of us
here
Byron loved inheriting this lord of the
manor stride around sword in hand you
know order the workers what to do next
be a man of what was country state and
my learning and reading as well only
trouble was virtually bankrupt they
could only afford to run the newsstand
estate what little money Byron had was
spent on sex drugs peacocks and poetry
you know so it never really got off the
ground and I think fairly shortly
thereafter maybe even before Byron died
in 1828 the estate was sold and all left
the Byron family completely but you said
Abbey was there and it brought with it
of course the rights of the family grave
Byron himself was buried in Hucknall
parish church and ADA said an upset her
husband and her mum mightily I want to
be buried next to my father in a parish
church
fortunately due to our friends and
colleagues in physics and sixty symbols
we're able to refer across because they
paid and visit to a terminus August tomb
in Cutler parish church and have done a
video on it and up there on the wall is
the clock commemorating Ada Lovelace
vertical she's not buried up there she's
down here in the family vault or
actually this is just the entrance to
the family vault at the funeral a
it was a small affair but really telling
was her mother did not attend I think
probably furious at her daughter's wish
to be buried next to the hated husband
Lord Byron Babbage was appointed
executor of aid as well but he didn't
attend either read into that what you
will but I think one can certainly say
that in the past in a despatched she was
a troubled soul in many ways there were
probably going Zhaan her various sorts
that we can only speculate about and yet
there's no doubt about it
I I don't want to underplay or overplay
ADA but she was important she really was
she she got it in a sense about software
and what software could do and I think
she sort of could transcend the
unbelievable limitations of the hardware
that would have been limited even had it
ever been built and could see beyond
that she could see beyond that to a
future of computing for its own sake if
you like that local link has been very
important to us as part of the
bicentenary celebrations of Ada you know
December 2015
everybody labels everything the Ada
Lovelace supported the Ada Lovelace
thing our excuse for doing this we've
labeled our first year lab as the Ada
Lovelace computing laboratory is that
there is this local connection I don't
know that she ever visited Newsted I
wish you probably live in London most of
us are life with her mom and I bet you
her mother
if there be any talk of a trip to news
they would have vetoed it because it
might um you know taking you too dear to
that man or something like that but yes
that is our local connection